the first quarterback of my Michigan
fandom indeed the coach of my team the
man who gave me the honor of
representing the team as an honorary
captain and a man who would tell me to
attack each day with an enthusiasm
unknown to the love to man common man is
there who's got it better than me nobody
Jim Harbaugh's on the Rich Eisen show
aren't you you there Jim I'm here rich
happy birthday Monday 50th big five oh
wow awesome big fun supposed to be I was
supposed to be at your surprise party
yeah Saturday night I heard that story
but you got caught up with being a
family man which is yeah yeah I got my
daughter's graduation party was that
Saturday night your graduation was
Thursday it's all kind of party was
Saturday so I wasn't able to make it up
you were the fun great time we were
surprised I was well you know what it
was it was a wonderful but might keep my
friends from back home from New York
City were there I had buddies of mine
from out here and you know mood showed
up and Michael Irvin Kurt Warner showed
up you know my buddy marshall faulk he
couldn't make it because his family
surprised him I would have been great to
have the old the old coach back right
there disappoint you weren't
disappointed that I was not at all not
well I mean look I would have loved to
have had you because you're you're
you're my coach you're my you're my guy
you're my guy
how's everything going what what what
does June look like for you right now
Jim what's going on June has been we've
done a lot of football camps okay and
we've doing a lot of recruiting so too
today as a matter of fact is a huge
weekend for us we're having an official
visit weekend here in Ann Arbor okay so
about B 15 to 20 official visitors and
then another maybe 15 unofficial
visitors it's so good it's nice it's
good not in here in Ann Arbor yes nice
and green and I bet you have the the
baseball team on right how about this
baseball team in the College World
Series
Jim how about so fun I mean when
pitching and fielding and padding I mean
they're all kinda come together it's a
beautiful thing to see and that's not
our team they have it going and they
they're playing as a team and we can
feel it we can feel we get this kid now
if we win this one
yeah and now we'll be go to the two out
of best out of two out of three
semifinal and it'll probably looking
like Vanderbilt huh it does look like
that it doesn't hey you know what it's
also interesting to since we chatted
last jawan Howard's now the coach of the
basketball team and Michigan's the only
institution of higher learning that's
got two former players representing the
basketball and football programs that is
amazing I mean who would have thought
right Jim both with initials KH that's
next level I don't even think about that
I did not even think about that that is
pretty cool it's really it's really cool
and Juwan has hit the ground running
he's uh he's working hard putting
together staff and and out recruiting
not you know future players but his own
players - I I can really see that
already already formed we got and we got
some really good players here already
and and JaJuan is going to be a great
coach force John Beilein was a great
basketball coach and a great basketball
coach is and JaJuan is you know we're
super excited here and in over to has
you want I'm fired up - I'm totally
fired up so you know are you gonna have
more honorary captains are you still
doing that yeah we're still doing that
okay still doing it we got what you got
think we're gonna have a good flight
this year good anything anything you
could spill any beans you could spill
negative announcements yeah what do you
got you got it yeah
yeah we got we're gonna honor the 69
team okay so that means Dierdorf comes
back there he'll be in the radio booth
so okay Kyle aw Tyler's going into the
Hall of Fame
yes yes okay so um that'll be great
paradoxes of the of the Brown Jug okay
little local flavor little local flavor
you got to take care of local all
politics are local I like it it just hey
look if you need me to let them know how
high the bar is set in terms of
speechifying I'm more than you just give
them my number I'll tell them at the how
high the bar is said Jim you know I mean
that's I I will tell them that I will
let that's how we do it so listen you
here be honorary cabs you get to talk to
the team yes and you got to watch this
watch this clip from Rich Eisen this is
how it's done how you do it you know
it's so funny it's so funny I stepped in
it we had Devin Bush on the show a few
weeks ago well just right before the
draft right and I'm talking to him and I
and I say to I'm not like so you were
there
you know a couple of seasons ago and
right around the middle of right around
middle of September somebody came and
gave a speech to your dear to your team
and I'm sure you know it was really
rowdy a really incredible speech right
and I just let it go like that he goes
yeah Tom Brady was great Tom Brady was
right I appreciate that you're both
created so I compare it's like very
Manning to Brady you know they're both
great I will take that I hate that means
I Eisen and Brady never both they're
both great it rolls off the tongue it
really does but it was really funny I'm
like no Devin I spoke to this to you to
it oh yeah that's right no I know gosh
you know I still under I loved your
interview of Mike Connolly that was
really good yeah funny where I said to
him like you had to go and get couple of
Michigan guys honey basically started
talking about how great Michigan is and
he goes and I realize I'm giving you
exactly what you're looking for right
now I'm like that is correct that's
fantastic I'm so glad you saw that eight
Jim thanks for calling and really means
a lot you are you're you're one of my
all-time favorites for many many reasons
so thanks for taking the time your enjoy
you continued fiftieth since it doesn't
sound like it's just one day it sounds
like it's isin thanks Jim I appreciate
thanks coach you take care
I like ya that said Jim our boy for more
of the Rich Eisen show tune - audience
Channel 239 on DirecTV for free on BR
Live or download the Rich Eisen show app